il est midi c'est le coup de feu dans
cette auberge de gastronomes au coeur de
la picarde
[Musique]
alexandre gauthier est un jeune chef à
seulement 28 ans il vient de décrocher
sa première étoile
trop cute
à 4 4 2
pour surprendre sa clientèle en quête de
nouveautés le chef a une arme secrète
un ingrédient précieux rare qu'il
conserve dans une pièce à l'écart
il doit monter le chercher à laitages
dans les combles du restaurant bien à
l'abri des odeurs de fourneaux à
l'intérieur d'une toute petite boîte
[Musique]
pourquoi c'est pas une boîte qui et
c'est un produit l'ombre d'un couac face
à dire il faut il faut il n'y a pas dans
cette boîte 20 grammes de safran acheté
au maroc
l'épicé la plus chère du monde la baule
avait bien sec mais bon on voit ce côté
rouge orangé les est tellement
particulier comme odeurs pour passeront
pas quoi à son pouvoir
il ya une odeur un peu sucré un peu
suave derrière qui et qui fait voyager
c'est évident ça c'est évident de retour
en cuisine le chef prépare une entrée de
sa création
potiron donc on a taillé qu'on a rappé
d'après ce qu'on a mis en copeaux
un coquillage qu'on a ouvert coup
et la petite touche qui va faire toute
la différence
le safran
voilà donc on laisse aux gens en général
l'homme est de 3 j'avais un peu plus de
3 7 pouces et pas beaucoup c'est très
puissant
dès qu'on l'aura en bouche il va amener
une chaleur un côté un peu sucré et très
floral en bouche tu fais que qui fait
que le plat le potiron sera toujours
présent mais va prendre des dimensions
différentes boucher après mon chef trois
pistils de safran qui suffisent à
sublimer un simple potiron le safran
l'or rouge comme on le surnomme tout le
monde en a entendu parler mais rares
sont ceux qui l'ont déjà goûté et pour
cause ces minuscules filaments coûte une
fortune
le safran est l'aliment le plus cher du
monde plus cher que la truffe ou le
caviar
il atteint jusqu'à 35 mille euros le
kilo et pour ce prix là le consommateur
n'est même pas sûr de ce qu'il achète
nous avons découvert que cette épice est
aujourd'hui la plus fraudée ça sent pas
trop le ca france
pourtant à la base le safran est un
vulgaire oignons qui coûte à peine 30
centimes d'euro
mais une fois par an il se métamorphose
en fleurs violettes et c'est là que se
cache le fameux pistil rouge vif qui
vaut de l'homme pourquoi le safran
coûte-t-il si cher les pistes fait-elle
la fortune de tous ceux qui la cultivent
quels sont les arnaques et comment les
déjouer nous sommes partis sur la piste
de l'épicé la plus chère du monde
[Musique]
notre enquête démarre dans le sud du
maroc au coeur des montagnes berbères de
l'atlas une région très austère
l'endroit idéal pour faire pousser du
safran 2000 mètres d'altitude
des hivers froids et des étés chauds ici
les paysans cultivent chaque année 2
tonnes de safran le maroc est le
quatrième producteur mondial derrière
l'iran l'inde et la grèce 5 heures du
matin dans le village du goon la scène
batali sa femme et ses filles quittent
la maison avant l'aube
direction les champs de safran la scène
ne possède pas grand chose
deux petites parcelles de safran héritée
de son père dans sa famille on vit du
safran de génération en génération
si toute la famille se lève aussitôt
c'est parce que les petites fleurs
violettes ont éclos pendant la nuit et
il faut vite les ramasser avant que le
soleil ne les abîmes lafleur est
capricieuse elle ne sort de terre qu'une
fois par an au moins de novembre et elle
n'accepte d'être cueillies à la main un
travail pénible pour récolter un seul
kilo de safran
il faut se baisser cent cinquante mille
fois quand on vieillit dans la région on
a tous des problèmes de rhumatismes
regardez mes mains elles sont toutes
abîmée à cause du froid
ça me fait mal c'est vraiment un travail
difficile
toute l'année il faut labourer arroser
désherber à la main il faut un grand
nombre de fleurs pour faire un kilo de
safran un travail énorme pour toute la
famille
et effectivement dans la famille tout le
monde participe même les plus jeunes
la scène où est-ce qu'elle va votre
fille elle va à l'école travaille le
matin à la cueillette et après elle va à
l'école après six heures de ramassage
la famille de la scène rentrer au
village ici depuis des siècles chaque
famille possède sa petite parcelle de
safran l'or rouge n'a enrichi personne
mais il est comme un cadeau du ciel qui
permet aux villageois de doubler leurs
revenus de l'année chez la scène la
famille est en plein travail
il décortique une à une les fleurs pour
en extraire chaque piste il
l'opération dure des heures leurs
voisins sont venus en renfort cette
année est un bon cru
la scène a récolté 2 kg le double de
l'année dernière
quel prix vous aller tirer de cette
récolte cette année j'espère vendre ma
récolte 6000 euros
6000 euros une somme importante pour la
scène au maroc le salaire moyen ne
dépasse pas 2400 euros par an quant aux
femmes
étonnamment elle ne verront pas la
couleur de cet argent
du moins pas officiellement est ce que
vous êtes payé pour faire ce que vous
faites là mais on prend la petite part
qui nous revient chaque jour on met un
peu de safran dans notre poche
les marchands ambulants passe ici ont
leurs échanges notre safran contre des
bagues des bijoux des vêtements et vous
avez le droit de le faire vous avez le
droit d'en prendre un petit peu près où
c'est mal vu
bah c'est notre salaire c'est notre
salaire acceptez-vous que ça c'est
normal qu'elles se servent un peu le
safran appartient à toute la famille
elles aussi elles ont le droit d'être
belle et d'acheter des bijoux et
aujourd'hui vous êtes servis ou pas oui
oui un petit peu qu'on aime à la fin de
la récolte les femmes auront tout juste
réussi à récupérer 30 euros chacune
la cueillette du jour tient dans une
assiette 20 grammes de safran seulement
après huit heures de travail de toute la
famille
la scène va ajouter ces 20 grammes à son
stock qu'il conserve précieusement sous
ce coffre de 30 kg
mais curieusement il ne va pas le vendre
tout de suite
moi j'attends que les prix augmentent
pour vendre parce que pour l'instant le
safran il y pas un bon prix dans quatre
mois
il y aura plus beaucoup de safran sur le
marché et du coup les prix vont grimper
c'est comme la bourse c'est comme la
bourse
ça monte jusqu'au mois d'août bourse ça
te descendre très bas aussi non le
safran sa baisse pas c'est une valeur
sûre c'est comme du cash tu trouvera
toujours preneur attendre comme la scène
que les prix grimpent
c'est un luxe que tous les agriculteurs
ne peuvent pas se permettre
pour vivre son voisin mahjoub lui doit
vendre sa récolte au plus vite dans le
plus grand souk de la région ils seront
à taliouine à 30 km du village
c'est dans cet immense marché
traditionnel que les grossistes viennent
de tout le maroc pour acheter leur
safran aux agriculteurs
dans son sac le vieux mahjoub transporte
sa fortune de l'hiver 200 grammes qu'il
va essayer de vendre au meilleur prix
bonjour ça va bien combien tu l'achètes
toi le safran c'est un euro 60 le gramme
non non c'est un euro 70 c'est ça le bon
prix et toi combien tu l'achètes le
safran 1 euros soit 100 kg 1 euro 60
c'est pas possible il a encore
dégringolé
c'est parce qu'il pleut quoi ces salles
est d'accord un euro 60 le gramme
ce jour là les acheteurs semblent s'être
mis d'accord sur ce prix salue comment
tu vas combien tu le prends au doigt mon
safran aller entre vient non non tu me
dis d'abord combien
allez mes jetons safran sur la balance
bon alors dis moi combien tu l'achètes
moi je l'achète en euros 60 le g et le
top du top
je prends un nouveau 65 mais je peux
vraiment pas faire plus
c'est de la bonne qualité 1
il est pas trafiqué tu peux vérifier
et il y en a 200 g bon allez d'accord je
te le prend 1 euros 70 voilà ton argent
380 euros
mahjoub est content de sa négociation
assez bien je me suis pas mal débrouillé
si je l'avais vendu 1 euro 60
je n'aurais même pas eu assez pour
rembourser mes dettes et acheter à
manger
en vendant son safran un peu plus cher
que prévu mahjoub a récupéré 20 euros
supplémentaires de quoi s'offrir
quelques pistaches de la viande et des
fruits pour une semaine mais ce que le
paysan est loin d'imaginer c'est que le
safran qu'il vient de vendre va
connaître dans les jours qui viennent
une inflation vertigineuse en période de
récolte le safran fait l'objet de toutes
les spéculations et la hausse des prix
commence de l'autre côté de la rue à 100
mètres du souk le même safran est
revendue deux fois plus cher aux
touristes
[Musique]
vous pouvez acheter la botte c'est 30
euros y'a 10 g j g dedans et pour ce
prix là le safran a été triés et
emballés 3 euros c'est vrai que c'est
cher france à 3000 euros le kilo le
stock de safran vaut une fortune plus
question d'une simple caisse endroits
comme chez la scène le paysan ici c'est
un vrai coffre fort blindés et pour
éviter les vols le directeur a fait
rajouter deux serrures pour l'ouvrir il
faut la présence des trois associés
chacun ne possède qu'une seule clé
encore fred est enfin ouvert
donc les trésors de la coopérative et
quelle quantité de safran 2 kg est à peu
près 2 kilo de safran
ça fait combien d'argent alors 12 kg
après ça fait 2 124 mille dirhams
emplois créés ça veut dire 24000 euros
c'est la banque à ce stade nous quittons
le safran à 3 euros le gramme
mais son prix peut grimper beaucoup plus
haut encore pour le comprendre
direction casablanca à l'autre bout du
pays 500 km et plusieurs intermédiaires
plus tard nous retrouvons le safran de
taliouine dans cette boutique haut de
gamme pour touristes
hélas le prix a atteint des sommets
combien
nous on leur à 12 euros le gramme cette
fois plus cher que le prix qu'on attire
l agriculteur au souk
mais ce n'est pas dans ce genre de
boutiques que les marocains viennent
acheter leur safran à agadir
nous nous rendons dans un marché
traditionnel les étals il regorge des
pis en tout genre
mais ici bizarrement les prix du safran
sont beaucoup plus raisonnables
chez cet épicier le gramme de safran ne
coûte que 2 euros 50
safran c'est 50 centimes de moins que le
prix payé par les touristes français à
taliouine quand on demande à cet autre
commerçant
il nous montre un pot où il y a bien
marqué safran pourtant il n'est pas de
la couleur rouge habituel celui là est
son prix est imbattable 50 centimes
d'euro le g qui dit mieux
le suivant nous propose un safran en
piste il est et il est bien rouge
il coûte deux euros cinquante et
pourtant ça sent pas trop le ca
française
intrigués nous décidons de faire
analyser ses produits dans un
laboratoire retour en france en seine et
marne dans l' usine de christophe gaudy
l'un des plus gros distributeurs de
safran il en importe deux tonnes par an
et le revend sous forme de dosettes dans
les hypermarchés français au prix moyen
de 3 euros le gramme
nous lui confions nos échantillons
marocain pour qu'il les analyses dans
son laboratoire pour le safran vendu 12
euros aux touristes dans le magasin de
luxe
pas de problème 100% safran
mais en observant nos autres
échantillons christophe gaudi est
beaucoup plus sceptique
ces filaments avait la couleur du safran
mais pas l'odeur
[Musique]
donc là bon il n'y a pas besoin de
beaucoup d'analystes pour être effrayés
quand on voit ces espèces damas comme ça
qui sont ni de la longueur du safran de
l'épaisseur d'un safran sont des fibres
végétales
ça n'a rien à voir avec du safran je
suis pas très rassuré parce que vous
ramenez salé maroc
d'habitude je mange le produit jusqu'au
jour où quand on a fait les analyses on
s'est rendu compte que j'avais mangé un
produit qui était totalement
je dirais dangereux cosmétiques qui
n'avait rien alimentaire donc depuis
cette époque je me méfie méfiant mais
curieux quand même mon assurance décès
la tête marché ça
c'est un gros indescriptible vraiment
chaud confiant que c'est un goût des
pistes type souk marocain un petit goût
boisé comme si c'était un petit copeau
de bois
peut-être un copeau de cyprès ont coloré
enfin non résolument rien à voir avec le
safran il nous a été vendu deux euros
cinquante le grain celui là vous en
pensez quoi
bah que je devrais changer de métier
vendre ça peut-être que j'aurai la
ferrari dans la société
l'échantillon suivant cette poudre
orange très bon marché que l'on nous a
vendu 50 centimes d'euro donc là bon ça
est résolument pas la couleur du safran
il ya deux produits qui me viennent à
l'esprit du curcuma ou du paprika ya pas
de doute c'est du paprika
maintenant on va ouvrir cet échantillon
numéro 3 enfin le safran sachet alors là
cet échantillon numéro 3 déjà vous voyez
le cellophane et les taches rouges
jaunes dans le sachet c'est pas du
safran parce que vous avez des tâches
carrément rouge
donc là on sait avant même d'avoir étalé
le produit d'hadrons mêmes mots couverts
le sachet que déjà c'est pas du safran
donc là quand vous regardez ce produit
là vous êtes quand même relativement
content parce que si vous avez payé ça
aussi 25 dirhams
c'est bien parce que contrairement au
produit tout à l'heure ça c'est un vrai
stigmates ça c'est un vrai stigmates ça
c'est un vrai stigmates
cette fraude est plus élaboré car au
milieu des brins d'il y a bien du vrai
safran donc ça c'est le genre de fraude
qu'on trouve assez fréquemment
parce que c'est une fraude qui a pour
but de vraiment même avoir des gens qui
connaissent un petit peu le safran donc
la bombe j'estime que vous êtes fait
avoir à moitié enfin dans tous les cas
hyper l'appellation safran du fait de ce
rajout
entre temps l'analyse scientifique
confirme le diagnostic de christophe
gaudy les trois échantillons sont tout
sauf du safran dans l'un des sachets il
y à bien des copeaux de sapins et dans
un autre les tests révèlent des
résultats plus inquiétant la présence
d'un colorant textile utilisé dans la
fabrication de vêtements un produit
cancérigène qui fraudent à quel niveau
se passe lors la tentation de fraude
elle est quand on vend à quelqu'un qui
n'a pas la connaissance
donc elle se fait généralement pas au
niveau des producteurs elle va se faire
dans les échelons qui vont être entre le
producteur et le consommateur final
en fait ça va être généralement le
dernier maillon de la chaîne qui va qui
va frauder
et nous avons découvert que le marché
français n'est pas épargné par la
contrefaçon
direction un marché populaire en plein
coeur de paris
bonjour vous rendez du safran soulever
après analyse il s'avère que le safran
vendus par cet épicier est en fait un
mélange de fibres végétales et de
colorants alimentaires
ce n'est pas du safran et pourtant sur
le flacon il y à bien en toutes lettres
la mention safran garanti pur nous
retrouvons exactement le même produit
frauder dans un autre magasin parisien
lâchait ce tracé de l'année pour tenter
de savoir d'où vient la fraude
nous nous rendons au siège de
l'entreprise qui commercialise ces
flacons il s'agit d'un grossiste qui
distribue des fruits et des légumes secs
ainsi que des épices
une responsable accepte de nous recevoir
malgré la présence de sa marque sur
l'étiquette
elle semble au départ ne pas reconnaître
son produit on a acheté différents
produits sur paris et on est tombé sur
celui ci on reconnaissait je ne vous
connais pas en tant que tel donc à
écrire dessus safran garanti pur c'est
ça vient pas de chez vous je peux pas
vous affirmez qui vient pas de chez moi
parce que parce qu'il y a marqué notre
nombre suffisamment probants la boutique
rue c'est chez vous oui on l'a acheté la
barre donc ça c'est quand même aussi
assez surprenant ça veut dire que c'est
quand même vous qui la vendent et celle
là d'accord il s'agit d'un produit
moi je il se trouve que celui ci n'est
absolument pas du safran il ya deux
colorants dans cette poudre tartrazine
et aux 124 et c'est tout sauf du safran
comment vous expliquez ça je ne peux pas
l'expliquer c'est à dire que vous mettez
en boîte des produits vous conditionner
par nom marque à l'étranger
donc vous avez été trompé par votre
fournisseur allemand et vous contrôlez
pas les produits que vous recevez nous
les contrôlons mais on contrôle pas
toutes les deux c'est impossible
vous écrivez sur l'étiquette safran
garanti pur
on imagine avoir du safran on l'a pas
c'est quand même grave
complètement je vais rapatrier des
produits je vais les mettre en
quarantaine jusqu'à temps de les faire
analyser
deux semaines plus tard pourtant ces
mêmes capsules de faux safran était
toujours en vente dans un marché
parisien
trois euros l'unité pour un coût de
fabrication de quelques centimes
seulement une fraude extrêmement
rentable
où
depuis quelques mois des agriculteurs
d'un nouveau genre ont réintroduit la
culture du safran en france alors qu'il
avait disparu depuis la révolution et ce
ne sont pas des nostalgiques mais des
petits malins qui ont compris que le
safran pouvait être très rentable
nous sommes à fond tanière au coeur de
la creuse
derrière cette clôture bien garder la
plus grande safranière de france dirigée
par véronique lazerat
il y a quelques années véronique et sa
famille vivait à paris mais elle avait
un vieux rêve
après des études de botanique elle
voulait vivre à la campagne
il lui manquait juste un projet et un
jour elle a eu le déclic
qu'est ce qui vous a fait penser au
safran tuez vous dire j'ai fait l'école
du breuil et je me souviens de mon
professeur de botanique qui avait sorti
parce qu'on a prouvé toutes les plantes
qui avait sorti un jour donc le cours
concernant le crocus sativus et qui
avait dit si l'un d'entre vous fait du
safran il sera le plus riche au kilo
mais le plus fatigué donc j'ai pas
encore riche mais fatigué peut-être
pourtant aujourd'hui le safran réussi à
faire vivre toute la famille
au départ le pari était loin d'être
gagné
personne n'avait jamais fait pousser
cette épice dans la creuse
véronique commence avec un petit champ
en friche et 5000 euros en poche pour
acheter les premières pousses de safran
comment vous avez pu vous dire je vais
faire pousser du safran dans la creuse
ça paraît complètement 20 c'était pas
gagné ça pouvait pousser la grèce parce
que ça poussait au cachemire et
cachemire
c'est des sols granitiques et acide
c'est pas le même c'est pas le même
climat du soleil on pense qu'il faut des
étés chauds et des hivers froids et la
moyenne montagne en france convient très
bien ses clients et le safran a
tellement bien pousser quand quatre ans
veronica quadruples et sa production
cette année ce sera une très bonne
récolte les fleurs sont très grandes
en plus de ça il ya eu un été très chaud
maintenant il fait froid on a encore du
soleil donc ça s'il fait ce temps là
tout mois d'octobre c'est parfait mais
pensez à combien tu as un bon du kilo à
deux kilos et demi un bond de kilos de
double en a deux kilos et demi la même
quantité produite chaque année par la
scène
le paysan marocain
sauf que véronique elle vend son safran
beaucoup plus cher car ses clients
restaurateurs haut de gamme et
particuliers sont prêts à payer le prix
fort pour un safran français garantie
non frauder
alors le prix que l'on fait à tous les
restaurateurs et professionnels c'est
toujours 30 euros le gramme qui prennent
un g qui prennent 100 grammes pour les
particuliers ce soit 34 euros le gramme
et 20 euros le 2030 euros le gramme
c'est tout de même dix fois plus cher
qu'au maroc mais pour ce prix là le
safran est présenté dans un bel écrin
donc on a fait un conditionnement on a
choisi un conditionnement de luxe parce
que bien souvent est très
malheureusement le safran était
commercialisé dans des peaux d'ours
recyclés ou alors dans des petits
sachets comme les sachets de cloud on
met pas voilà un produit de luxe dans un
emballage plastique genre pilule
médicaments et véronique à de nombreuses
idées pour que son produit de luxe lui
rapporte toujours plus avec son mari
daniel ils fabriquent une confiture au
safran
la recette est simple des fruits du
jardin du sucre et à peine 2 pistils de
safran par pau une toute petite pincée
qui va permettre à cette redoutable
femme d'affaires de doubler le prix de
son pot de confiture elle levant 5 euros
et elle réussit à en écouler quatre
mille pop art en bénéfice net
seize mille euros rien qu'en confiture
est comme ça marche
véronique mais c'est pistils de safran
un peu partout elle a convaincu des
artisans de la région de rajouter son
safran dans des produits inattendue dans
du nougat dans du chocolat et même dans
du foie gras
[Musique]
des produits qu'elle vend directement
aux consommateurs
trois fois par semaine véronique ouvre
sa safranière au public
il ya des retraités qui viennent prendre
du safran pour aller à la pêche pascal
infuse on les a pas on a très facilement
et poissons et après la madame est bas
et cuisiner le poisson
la visite est payante bien sûr 10 euros
par personne
et pour ce prix là les participants ont
droit à un parcours bien rodé ça
commence par un petit tour dans les
champs de safran donc vous cueillez
comme comme des pâquerettes voilà les
fleurs voilà donc quand on a la 150 ça
fait 1 g
on va vous montrer les montages ensuite
petite leçon de découpage du pistil on
va plonger dans la feuille ciseaux et
coupé donc à la base sur piste ils sont
les séparer voilà qu'il faut renouvela
fleurs voilà chaque piste il ya environ
1 100 euros
et pour finir le passage obligatoire par
la boutique de souvenirs
si vous voulez du safran ses 20 ans le
petit pot et 34 peau d'un gramme en
général ça vous dure une année info d'un
gramme a su remettre ça dans un sac
49 euros naudin et de la confiture de
figues des nougats et de la confiture
d'ananas avec son safran véronique
réalise un chiffre d'affaires de 100
mille euros par an de quoi faire des
émules
le lendemain matin ce sont des visiteurs
d'un autre type qui arrive chez
véronique aurélie et françois lesueur
viennent du berry ils ont fait 300 km
ils viennent d'acheter un lopin de terre
pour produire eux aussi leur safran des
stagiaires viennent de toute la france
chez véronique pour suivre une formation
intensive de quatre jours
ils veulent tout savoir pour être
capable une fois rentrés chez eux de
cultiver leur propre safran dans le
berry en bretagne ou sur la côte d'azur
en suivant le modèle de véronique ils
sont persuadés de pouvoir en vivre
confortablement les anciens stagiaires
ont à ce jour créer une centaine de
safranières un peu partout en france est
ton à l'aube d'une révolution dans nos
assiettes
va-t-on manger demain du safran à toutes
les sauces ces jeunes entrepreneurs y
croit dur comme fer mais leur
enthousiasme est peut-être due à une
vertu méconnu du safran ça fait rigoler
les peas est impuissante euphorisant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]